[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue au lac des
deux sont mis à briller 2 c'est une
histoire ou merci à vous très très fort
d'être aussi nombreux sur la chaîne
maintenant ça fait trois ans et demi
qu'elle existe et c'est beaucoup trop
cool donc bienvenue à tous ceux qui sont
arrivés récemment et puis le bienvenu
aussi à tous ceux qui sont là depuis
très longtemps je vous aime tous très
fort alors ça sort pour fêter cet
événement eh ben on est au youtube space
avec plein de copains qui vont venir
jouer un petit quizz historique des
familles super chouette inspiré du
burger quiz que vous allez voir
j'ai donc plein d'invités et j'ai fait
exprès de prendre des invités qui
faisait pas d'histoire a priori fin ou
alors union cacher comme ça je vais le
challenge est un peu dessus mais ils
sont en équipe donc ils vont pouvoir
s'épauler les uns les autres parce que
c'est avant tout un truc d'esprit
l'équipe france j'espère on verra du
coup je vais appeler les invités un par
un mais sachez que pendant le jeu
pendant la première manche tu vas y en
avoir trois ans tous vous pouvez dès à
présent poser vos questions faq dans le
dans le tchat
puisque il va y avoir des intermèdes des
interludes de faq avec avec moi même
vous pouvez poser toutes les questions
que vous avez à me poser les questions
vous avez à poser à bartier notre
cadreur et réalisateurs et les questions
vous avez à poser à limoux lucie note
dessinatrice qui a fait les deux
derniers épisodes animés que vous avez
peut-être vu donc la vidéo sur le
cannibalisme et la drogue des nazis que
vous avez eu l'air de kiffer une
longueur de très content des retours
donc sans plus attendre
et bien je vais faire entrer la première
équipe donc l'équipe number one
le premier membre de cette équipe et pas
des moindres c'est théo sa lutte et au
bout un petit bisou merci d'être là pas
du tout préparés installe toi donc que
tes os quand une petite phrase tu peux
nous pitch et achêne non tu sais très
bien que j'arrive d'appeler fait ça
c'est une chaîne qui parle
essentiellement de sciences dures avec
un semblant poésie
un peu de mal à jouer parce que
maintenant tu acceptes de dire que la
poésie j'ai travaillé au corps pour ça
pour voir passez moi l'expression
deuxième membre de l'équipe us
il s'agit de les couler le salut qu'à
bien parce qu'on s'imagine une foule en
délire mais on est tombé dans un
fastidieux et c'est très mignon mais je
suis surtout des berges à toi votre
caméra vous êtes en train d'applaudir
comme des derniers tout seul chez vous
ou peut-être à plusieurs si vous avez
déjà je vous le souhaite
les as tu veux bien pitcher tâche et non
une petite phrase oui bah c'est une
chaîne de science c'est la chaîne du
cnra c'est lui qui s'appelle j'ai pas
dis vous êtes adoption étonnant futa
patinant si longtemps malade mentalement
tacle et pardon cesse de science voilà
donc c'est une chaîne qui vulgarise
chance toutes thématiques des actualités
de recherche et c'est la chaîne lui
celle du cnrs tout à fait et troisième
membre de cette équipe
il s'agit de jean baptiste way salut
jean baptise sa loi oui tu peux
rejoindre ta petite équipe sur le canapé
donc c'est l'équipe rhin grande équipe
un grand groupe qui part de très grande
et il déjà une belle brochette jb tu
veux 13 ans et achèvement une petite
phrase oui normalement le nom s'affiche
lacets cinéma avec un s devant le sait
et ça se prononce cinéma parce que je
fais de la science avec du cinéma
après les révélations scientifiques avec
est tout à fait mais ça non
dans une vidéo de tuer plutôt cyprien
faire je suis complètement cyprien les
verts selon lui faire un petit coucou
nous allons accueillir sans tarder la
deuxième équipe allons alors parlons
juste avant une sorte que vous avez un
petit nom d' équipes de derrière les
fagots
ok encore eût-il fallu que je le sus
encore eût-il fallu que je sus quelle
bombe au nom d' équipe qui se prête à
parler de quiproquos j'aime beaucoup
équipe 2 nous allons donc avoir d'abord
le capitaine
salut capitale oui ça vas y toi installe
alors le capitaine donc du nexus s qui
va nous présenter sa chaîne pour ceux
qui éventuellement ne la connaissent pas
non mais tu es chaîne qui parle de
science fiction qui parle de science
fiction dans la littérature le jeu vidéo
le cinéma mais le projet c'est aussi de
faire une web série puisque en fait vous
allez suivre nos aventures ses aventures
de deux mois de mon équipage sur le
vaisseau de lexus is attendant la
direction d'enquêté spéciaux du gunfight
du dog fights ce que tu es en train de
justifier ton et gül s'était pas et j'ai
pas encore à justifier puisqu'on n'a pas
encore fait les épisodes étaient
financés grâce parfait deuxième membre
de cette équipe il s'agit de julien vous
pouvez éventuellement vous applaudir
s'est tenue place en tête des gens donc
ça c'est l'équipe complète
j'ai bien ri gueur petit présente et
hachée pour ce qui peut-être ne la
connaîtraient pas oui je suis adrien
manière du collectif colonnes moustache
du fait des vidéos d'humour le
benamrouche vidéo sur tout ce qui est
physique que tu pars du principe que les
jours de connaître parce que la chaîne
parle de santé voilà et de corps humains
et elle s'appelle s'appelle donc été
normalement c'était crise où vas tu es
sauvaitre écran voilà sur votre groupe
se soude way en bas de votre écran parce
qu'il soit repensé avec moi donc qu'on
irait chez eux et quel âge avait créé sa
commande la grosse ambiance et troisième
membre de l'équipe il s'agit de nico ils
arrivent déjà en faisant la tête je le
reconnais bien là très fier d'être
angélique aux serveurs oui parce que tu
va nous présenter ta chair bien sûr et
bien fait bah écoute
nicolas et c'est une chaîne qui
s'appelle pilote c'est qu'ils parlent de
série et tu nous as fait un grand retour
et ça c'est ça après un an et demi
d'absence
mais quel retour sur les fins de série
11 pas la fin de la chaîne ce qui
n'annonce pas la fin de la chaîne soit
je trouve que tu aurais pu un peu jouer
là dessus
or c'est faux
bref on va pas au hockey alors je vous
explique les règles normalement vous
vous les connaissez mais je vais les
expliquer pour le public n'oubliez pas
que vous pouvez poser vos petites
questions faq si vous en avez si vous en
avais pas que bharti ici on discute
france en tout à l'heure on a plein de
trucs et astuces
ça fait longtemps qu'on avait pas vu
alors le principe c'est que je vais vous
poser à chaque équipe une question mais
à tour de rôle cette première manche
n'est pas l'épreuve de vitesse
ok donc d'abord une question pour
l'équipe 1 ensuite une question pour
l'équipe 2 donc vous pouvez discuter
entre vous et réfléchir et c'est le
principe c'est que je vais vous donner
trois propositions et vous allez devoir
me dire laquelle est vrai ou laquelle
les fausses en fonction de la question
d'accord vous pouvez réfléchir entre
vous à chaque fois tranquillement et
vous me donnez votre réponse on compte
les points si jamais à la fin de la
manche juillet inégalités vous allez
avoir trois questions pour chaque équipe
on fera juste une toute petite épreuve
de rapidité au buzzer pour vous
départager avec un truc très très facile
ok et bah oui j'ai évité désactiver
temps avec les baisers voilà alors vers
dommage donc première question pour
l'équipe donc vous évidemment je vous
déconseille de de leur donner la réponse
voilà mais bon vous pouvez ou alors la
difficulté du tribunal alors journée
c'est ptet pas si facile que ça de faire
des questions que j'ai eu peur qu'elle
soit pas forcément oui c'est vrai à ces
serbes
l'accès laquelle de ces propositions est
vrai donc c'est une question pour
l'équipe 1 en encore eût-il fallu que je
le que je moi que je baise c'est vrai
vous votre nom d' équipe c'est là ce
n'est pas le dire pourquoi moi mais par
annoncer beaucoup mieux que ça c'est les
raids space a remis le raid space ami ok
oui et je voulais aussi dire que ont
fait une petit un petit coucou à blaise
de la chaîne de la chronique qui devait
être avec vous dans l'équipe mais qui
malheureusement est un empêchement
c'était mon petit poulain du concours
déplorons le fait un gros bisou mais
tant pis tant pis pour cette fois mais
on pense à toi blesse son bulletin pense
à toi d'électron libre l'ancien tar
choses un peu finalement
mais il m'a dit aujourd'hui disposer
métadatas et bien je déjà alors on va
peut-être y aller parce que sinon ça va
durer deux heures se lève donc première
première question laquelle d'équipement
seller encore eût-il fallu que je le
suis
laquelle de ces propositions est vraie
réponse à alors la question devrait
s'afficher sur l'écran normalement non
au régime
alors je pense à louis saez et le
dernier roi de france
réponse b charles 10 et le dernier roi
de france réponse c'est louis philippe
est le dernier roi de france laquelle
est vrai vous pouvez discuter entre vous
et trouver la réponse vous avez pensé
lui
non parce que les anglais il en
remettant sur le trône après la
révolution après sa vie à qui ridiculise
il décapite d'où cette impression là ce
temps c'est pas lui
je sais pas on va passer pour le dernier
roi des cons en fait j'ai fait exprès de
prendre personne qui sait tout ça mais
je dirais charge 10 mai mais je me dis
moi c'est mon voisin de palier mais
d'accord alors votre réponse et la sccv
ou c
eh ben je ne sais pas j'en ai aucune
idée
alors vous dites la réponse b et alors
avant quand on affiche la vraie réponse
sachez que louis saez a régné jusqu'en
1792 charles 10 araignée jusqu'en 1830
et louis-philippe araignée jusqu'en 1848
sauf que et vous n'êtes pas tomber dans
le piège mais juste parce que vous ne
saviez pas rien charles ghislain dernier
roi de france parce que louis philippe
était le dernier roi des français
il n'avait pas pris le métier mais on
apprend des trucs
du coup bah justement trop fort c'est
pas mal en fait
or est le philips est un roi qui membres
ouais bon pour l'équipe griffiths et
c'est un roi qui a essayé de composer
avec l'héritage aussi révolutionnaire
son père il avait il faisait partie des
meubles qu'ils étaient des rares notes
qui était pro révolution est donc lui
quand il est monté sur le trône après
une révolution qui a renversé le char le
disent d'ailleurs il est il a pris le
titre de roi des français parce que
c'était un peu moins vous comprenez
c'est un peu comment dire voyez la
différence symbolique entre rois de
france ces genres le terme il appartient
est roi d'effacer ya ton peuple et voilà
exactement
donc voila c'était un piège mais mais
bon vous n'êtes pas tomber dedans bravo
aux joueurs à vous équipe 2 laquelle de
ces propositions est fausse les fausses
ok aphrodite est la fille de zeus
aphrodite et la femme de zeus aphrodite
et la tante de zeus
il y en a qu'une seule qui est fausse
mais parce que des formations la
mythologie différentes versions d'un
coup moi spontanément je dirais lasser
mais moi j'en étais la première comme je
connais pas la hiérarchie
exact mais au dessus d'eux c'est le
[Musique]
savez nous les trucs comme ça enfin les
trucs les titans tout ça est pour moi
aphrodite ça a toujours été une baisse
en dessous de 2
donc je n'aurais pas dit que ce serait
sa tendre tu vas mais [ __ ] dans la
mythologie grecque
non barrette comme je ne sais pas
répondre je réfléchis comme ça mais ça
ils ont des noms se ridiculiseront des
tentes et des degrés de savoir ce serait
là tu trouves ça trouve non non moi je
pense que le piège
je sais qu'un pense que c'est un piège
mais alors quand à la d alors qu'en fait
c'est là c'est très clair mais parce
qu'il veut trouver quoi qu'est ce que tu
nous réfléchir sinon bah c'est là c'est
là ses lacets alors je dit que la
réponse folle et du poulet et bien c'est
l'abbé non alors alors pourquoi parodier
bernière de nom du club dorothée
alors
vous je vous donne la petite explication
donc effectivement ça paraît tout à fait
contradictoires qu'elles soient à la
fois la fille est latent dont il y avait
bien un piège alors maintenant partir du
principe que si ça vous semble être un
piège c'est dans le nord de la france et
voilà dédicace en nord pas de calais on
vous aime merci d'être en fait donc
suivant les versions on n'a pas la même
généalogie en effet dans chez homère
dont dans l'iliade et l'odyssée
elle est la fille de zeus et dans la
théogonie d'hésiode lé mais j'ai pas
trop aimé des dons d'organes aux chronos
a tranché et jeté dans l'eau et chronos
et le père de zeus donc si elle est la
soeur et la tombe pour avoir cité
chronos
non mais c'est quoi cette histoire m'a
doublement c'est pas le but alors hier
d'être encore ici il fallu que je le
suis zéro point pour la l'équipe des
gagnants deuxième question pour l'équipe
j'ai plus besoin de ça laquelle de ces
propositions est fausse a les sept
merveilles du monde ont été établis dans
l'antiquité
b le colisée est une des sept merveilles
du monde sait et ne reste qu'une seule
des sept merveilles du monde à qu'elle
est fausse tête à tête à tête
salah vous l'avez
babylon et ses phares l'alexandrie
content mais l'on va tout est établi
dans sa colosse de rhodes
il ya les jardins alors il n'y en a
qu'une qui était la clique est fausse
mais manon ses toiles à merveille du
monde voilà ça les suppléments d'accord
jordana ça mange pas honnêtement et non
en fait j'ai du mal à comprendre ce mois
quant à elle frau c'est la question
qu'on parle déjà permis à la vigne en a
2 devrait à nouveau ouvrir en ces termes
c'est la première fois alors si wayne et
sept merveilles du monde antique heat et
son big la boue ouais ouais vas être
relou sur le mot s'arrête antiquités ben
là c'était l'avant après c'est un peu
[Musique]
est ce qu'il aura sur moi une bombe le
resto moi oui il en reste au moins parce
qu'il est je la tiens tu prépares une
jeune je crois pas que ce soit en
dessous on voit pas et il y en a une
alors il y en a là c'est une arme il
n'en reste qu'une chambre ont fait un
chiffre au mix d où cette année c'est
qu'il n'y en a qu'une seule qui faussent
parmi ces trois oui non pas quand mais
il n'y a qu'une seule ce we la dernière
proposition dit qu'il reste qu'une seule
des sept merveilles où je miserais sur
la bbc
jamais entendu pareille colisée qu'on
ait tant de merveilles du moins m'étonne
donc seul ce qui m'étonne le plus beau
ou dit laver j'adore parce que c'est
totalement larache mais vous avez juste
le fait n'est pas une des sept
merveilles du monde
en effet les sept merveilles du monde
ont bien été établi dans l'antiquité
alors en fait il ya plusieurs listes ya
plus via plusieurs listes mais la liste
canonique elle comprend alors je ne sais
pas par coeur mais je vous les donne
comme ça je sais pas vous étiez sans
doute en train de vous dire mais c'est
quoi déjà les sept merveilles du monde
selon moi merci non le fameux le faire
après il ya un truc à chypre non je vous
les donne
les jardins les jardins suspendus de
babylone la statue crise éléphantine de
zeus à olympie le temple d'artémis à
ephèse le mausolée d'halicarnasse le
colosse de rhodes le phare d'alexandrie
et la pyramide de khéops qui est la
dernière de sept merveilles du monde qui
existent encore alors sachez qu'il y
avait quand même aussi un piège mais
vous êtes beaucoup trop fort c'est qu'en
fait le colisée il ya il existe non au
contraire je te mets en valeur
en fait s'il existe un nouveau
classement des sept merveilles du monde
moderne qui a été fait par par nom par
une fondation totalement privée par une
fondation totalement privée qui
s'appelle en anglais les 7 merveilles
nouvelle merveilleuse et qui avait mis
le colisée dedans voilà les nouvelles
c'est la grande muraille de chine petra
la statue du christ à rio le machu
picchu le site au mexique de chiché
nizza et le taj mahal donc cet entêtant
ce deuxième point pour l'équipe vaut 15
points et si on répond bien on a gagné
pas du tout non ouais bon deuxième
question pour l'équipe de la quête de
ces propositions est fausse aujourd'hui
les grecs faisait des sacrifices humains
les romains faisait des sacrifices
humains
les incas faisait dix ans qu'ils
détiennent donc il ya des pièges donc
c'est pas les incas déjà pas évident
magharebia les aztèques étudiants et ça
se trouve tu es dans notre imaginaire et
là oui il y avait des gens des vagues
dessus des sacrifices mais ces
désaccords
en fait je suis sûr que le nom qui ne
vous est pas mais c'est pourquoi n'ont
ils ont avancé la démocratie c'est un
peu moi je pense que je verrais bien des
sacrifices qu'ils ne faisaient pas de
sacrifice
les romains les incas ou les grecs non
plus parce que moi je dirais la taille
comparé patenema on parle de chagriner
faire genre dans un rituel pour une
divinité entre commerçants mais genre
les jeux du sort c'est considérer
comment ces sacrifices pas le jeu la
méga les romains les gens qui habitaient
à rome où la civilisation gréco-romaine
mais rome jusqu'à quelle date en fait
parce que enfin aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de dire suivez votre ancien de quoi
m'attendre
tous les gens sont âgés suivre votre
instinct sauf qu'on a dit une blouse
truc tu as donc tout ça aux nôtres en
soins moi je ne sais pas les cinq a321
ce temps on a deux un certain succès
avec tf1 san jose calif
ça vous fait éliminer un trouble et zinc
aztèque c'était toute la partie carrière
des andes etc
un cas c'était mexique sont levés comme
ça mais je réfléchis
c'est donc pour moi les dunks imposer
des sacrifices humains mais sauf qu'elle
va nous dire non à ceux d'avant
distendre évoqué l'amérique centrale les
deux noms ils s'en seraient mais du coup
mais moi dans mon lit j'ai légère je ne
sais pas lequel des deux faisait les
sacrifices humains et du coup je suis un
petit peu perdu ces dons d'organes et
les aspects du jeu je ne veux pas sa
mort je fais confiance à renault n'ont
pas fait rire non je me disais c'est
l'équipe de voiture c'est bon au niveau
elle s'en suivrait pas moi je me fais
confiance au 6 mai par modestie je
réponds non
tu dis que c'est les grecs pour toi tu
es pour les vainqueurs je m'en fous
l'actrice amber santé les romains
avaient toutes été remplies je suis sûr
qu'on y est je suis cool et vendre un
point et donc est donc alors on pourrait
juste expliqué très vite donc les incas
alors les incas déjà c'est une
civilisation qui est beaucoup plus
tardive par rapport aux deux autres
parce que c'est plutôt c'est plutôt 13e
16e siècle si je me trompe pas et on n'a
pas de deux traces archéologiques en
tout cas de grecs qui ont fait des
sacrifices humains même si dans la
mythologie grecque il y a beaucoup
d'histoires de sacrifices donc ça prouve
et mon 1 er mai sont les sept ans le
savez pas quels sont les trucs sur les
vernis sur les roannais non mais l'homme
était bien sûr
les romains on a c'est très très rare
mais on a des quelques témoignages
pendant la république donc entre 509
avant et 44 avant notre ère de deux cas
très isolés de sacrifices humains mais
apparemment ça va pas mal choqué les
romains eux mêmes mais on en a et
l'elysée les incas sacrifier des enfants
alors dieu l'irak au chat que je prend
certainement pas qu il faut probablement
pas donc pas de points pour l'équipe 2
du coup j'ai pas de compteur pour les
points mais on va essayer de s'en
rappeler est-ce qu'on peut rattraper
notre voisine où on a joué jusqu'au bout
non non jamais paru et non en plus vous
y allez pour une équipe tout ce j'ai
sauté un truc je crois oui
équipe 1 laquelle de ces propositions
est vrai la suisse a accordé le droit de
vote aux femmes
avant la france l'os bkis temps à
accorder le droit de vote aux femmes
avant la france le mexique a accordé le
droit de vote aux femmes
avant la france laquelle est vrai en
gros le cas de ces pays à accorder le
droit de vote aux femmes
avant la france laquelle ça serait pas
les trois un truc un peu mais non c'est
pas piéger sur la question il faut
choisir
l'acquéreur lequel de ces pays
l'ouzbékistan
non mais justement bonus en faisaient
déjà attendant un problème avec
l'ouzbékistan pour moi c'est que ça peut
pas être excitant parce qu'il apparaît à
la chute de l'urss donc ça voudrait dire
que on l'a fait après 89 ou donc pas
bien quoi ah non à bas prix aux lois que
c'est vrai que l'ouzbékistan il apparaît
après les galères un centre je pense
qu'on va devoir passer la cinquième un
petit peu
jette la balle aux big is a accordé le
droit de vote aux femmes en 1938 la
france en 1944 et le mexique en 1953 et
la suisse en 1971 expliqué parce que
l'ouzbékistan fait partie dû à geroy les
tours genre de truc du coup je me sens
qu'on tumaco les cimes de chez vous et
que vous avez la réputation des objets
légèrement en accueillant dépendra pas
que les états on a de la réponse à la
question vous êtes sport équipe 2
laquelle de ces propositions est vrai
encore l'homo sapiens on n'a jamais
connu les mammouths cléopâtre n'a jamais
connu les pyramides d'égypte d'egypte
ch'ti le t-rex et le diplodocus ne se
sont jamais connu ça c'est faux je vais
donc quand tu dis cléopâtre n'a jamais
connu pareille d'egypte c'est à dire tu
parles pas de la construction tu parles
pas quelle était la neige
oui bon ok qu'à l'élysée comment ça ça
c'est vrai parce que ça a été fait avant
que le vote d'hier est donc laquelle de
ces propositions est vrai j'ai rêvé
sapiens n'a jamais connu a connu là bas
on n'a jamais connu donc celle là est
fausse ok t'es tu viens de dire attendez
ferme ils ont été construites avant ce
que tu attends les avants avant eux
oui donc oui et les à côtés tout voilà
longtemps donc c'est faux donc c'est pas
ça on était l'homo sapiens n'a jamais
connu et mammuth je dirais que dans
astérix mission cléopâtre ils sont en
train de la construire comme pendant par
contre le tir accès direct c'était le
crétacé lights crétacé je crois le
diplodocus peut-être avant peut-être
est-ce que tu bluffes chaque fois qu'il
touche
longueuil elle jouera creek autre chose
comme ça moi j'aimerais plutôt lasser
l'homo sapiens j'attends le piège dans
des ballons c'était en fait le mot
habilis mais bon le mobile
donc moi je pense au delà est vrai
laquelle ces propositions oui mais qui
devrait s'élargir et la vraie parce que
sinon ces diplômés d'hocus pour moi il
songe à ben non les connaisseurs
je savais pas budgétée plus en plus que
je m'habitue alors l'accès je dois
réfléchir à mon tour voilà alors en fait
copé tous deux réseaux je sais pas je
m'en fous moi j'ai plus rien moi je dis
comme julien lauprêtre
la cca peu de réponses alors oui ça
vient est apparue il ya environ 300
millions et le mammouth a disparu il ya
environ 2000 ans ce qui fait qu'ils se
sont connus
cléopâtre est né en effet alors c'est
que l'opa de cette d'ailleurs quand on
indiqué au patron parce qu'on est plein
mais elle est née vers 69 avant
jésus-christ en effet les pyramides
enfin quand on alors les pyramides bon
ça veut tout et rien dire mais pensons
la pyramide de khéops par exemple a été
construite il ya environ 2000 enfin en
verre environ 2500 avant et le
diplodocus a vécu entre environ il y à
154 entre environ il y à aussi librement
parce que je vais donner deux enfants
produit agit en viande
merci entre environ il ya 150 millions
d'années et 152 millions d'années et le
t-rex entre environ 68 millions d'années
et 70 millions d'années ils se sont
jamais connu petit pied vous a menti
voilà alors c'est donc une victoire de
l'équipe 1 bravo les gars où je vais
vous inviter à quitter tranquillement le
plateau rien du tout juste ma
reconnaissance et peut-être de nouveaux
abonnés nico enfin je sais pas s'ils ont
mis au rebus de ligue 1 sont tachées de
peinture elle je vais vous inviter à
quitter plateau les amis et je vais
accueillir lucie et ensuite bart pour la
faq petit interlude le temps que les
équipes échangent leur micro etc
je laisse le buzz et remercie et
et du coup vous pouvez vous reviendrez
nous dire au revoir après mai mais vous
avez tout donné les cas c'était mignon a
tout à leur équipe ainsi fort ça sent
que vous êtes des vrais vulgarisateur
est-ce que l'uci et par là pour venir me
rejoindre pour la faq lucie c'est donc
mais mu cool si coucou petit bisou on a
un petit rituel fois la voie là parce
qu'on sait pas tarder à lui avant
l'heure c'est pas du tout violent et moi
non plus et j'ai vraiment vraiment pas
comment ça va lui si ça va bien et en
est ce que tu veux te présenter un petit
peu pour les géants toujours en haut et
bas vous ne connaissez pas le visage de
l'huissier a priori sur la chaîne et
pourtant elle a tant donné dernièrement
alors représenter toi alors je m'appelle
bus y est
mon pseudo sur les internets ses limites
et
je travaille dans dessins animés à paris
et dernièrement aussi sur youtube
en fait avec manon way et donc on fait
des petites vidéos rigolotes que vous
avez sûrement vu en fait et
qui était sur nos dernières vidéos bas
sur les nazis la drogue le cannibalisme
des choses sympas bonne ambiance
grand sourire on est des personnes
saines d'esprit et autant j'aille de ouf
voilà et c'est bien le bloc donc donc
c'est l'uci qui a fait les dessins
animés si vous les avez vu vous a été
assez nombreux à les voir on était hyper
renault de des retours dessus et on va
accueillir bart il est presque il est
prêt barthélémy et après un petit bisou
ouais parce qu'on sait pas mais c'est
pas pour toi tu veux pas faire les mêmes
blagues que moi alors bon petit bar tu
es ce que tu veux te présenter toi aussi
oui bien sûr donc vous l'avez vu
quelquefois par ouais moi c'est bart je
suis le cadre un réalisateur de c'est
une autre histoire depuis le début
toutefois on peut le dire et c'est pas
mon activité principale moi je suis
opérateur caméra dans la publicité
voilà ce que répond déjà une question du
chat on peut pas commencer les questions
quand elle a normalement mais voilà vous
avez posé des questions sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'on a relevé et dans le chat
et lucie et barton en regard des notes
allant de chat pendant que je posais des
questions aux équipes donc bel et bien
allons-y et j'espère que vous nous avez
relevé des questions cool alors déjà en
vacances hors dire que oui c'est un live
en fait parce qu'on a eu pas mal de
maintenir sa démission
oui tout à fait conduites non mais c'est
trop fake c'est pas du lala justement
profite pour remercier le youtube space
et toute l'équipe en fait on a la chance
d'avoir un énorme très gros staff mais
en fait blanc toro et on est bien en
live c'est bien c'est bien du direct
comment pourrait le prouver à personne
en particulier dont on citera pas le nom
pour pas lui faire de pub mais c'est
clairement je pense qu'il voulait qu'on
aille leaké match n 1
ok on peut être la mienne mais la sienne
j'ai rien compris mais c'est normal
ouais c'est fluide et un peu qu'ils
disent et c'est pas vrai là il c'est pas
vrai lille ça enregistrait sa enregistré
tout allait souvent réplique c'est un
live les avis il va là parce que j'ai
pas comment on pourrait le prouver qu
est ce qu on pourrait enfin jeune homme
ça veut dire que c'est super bien fait
c'est la magie
après la d'après les prochaines équipes
on revient pour refaire des facultés
sont autant n'hésitez pas à poser des
questions très précises et alors alors y
at il des bas dit mrap des questions
pour vous d alors on a une question qui
revient vas tu faire 200 mille points
sur une feuille
alors ça c'est pour les aficionados qui
connaissent la vidéo des 10000 abonnés
c'était un petit moment ça partait les
miens c'était rien trois ans la chaîne
il existe depuis trois ans et demi
maintenant
et oui c'est vrai que pour les 10000
abonnés en fait j'avais eu envie
d'europe de matérialiser ce que ça
faisait dix mille personnes parce que
10000 personnes c'est très très cool
mais c'est pas énorme énorme comme
chaîne youtube
mais du coup j'avais envie de s'asseoir
concret et qu'on se rende compte à quel
point ça faisait beaucoup de monde du
coup rien fait des points sur des
feuilles en trichant un peu en faisant
des photocopies
mais voilà c'était l'idée la plus anti
écolo et là on est moins après ever que
j'ai jamais eu et j'ai décidé de pas le
refaire pour les palier suivant
du coup c'est un petit historique pour
ceux qui suivent la chaîne depuis dix
mille abonnés il est vrai que ça nous a
suivi c'est vrai qu'on l'avait pas fait
pour les cent mille on le fera de fumer
mais j'ai apprécié que vous ayez la réf
ouais on a su lui pour toi pourquoi tu
démarres youtube quelle a été ta
motivation
alors j'ai commencé d'abord parce que
quand j'étais en thèse j'ai fini en juin
dernier mais quand j'ai commencé la
chaîne j'étais en thèse d'histoire et
j'ai participé à un concours organisé
par le sénat ce qui s'appelle matt et
180 secondes où les doctorants doivent
présenter en trois minutes leur sujet au
grand public et j'avais beaucoup aimé
l'expérience on a eu de la formation à
la médiation scientifique c'était très
cool et j'avais le prix du public à la
finale régionale de midi-pyrénées
ce qui ne qualifie pas pour la finale
nationale mais qui était une super
reconnaissance parce que ça voulait dire
que la majorité de la salle avait été
avait été conquise du coup je m'étais
dis bien peut-être un public pour le ton
et les sujets qui sont les miens et
ensuite avec bart
on avait fait la petite vidéo sur
toulouse au détail si vous l'avez vu sur
la chaîne pour participer à un concours
de courts métrages à l'époque je l'avais
dit aujourd hui de faire une vidéo lui
c'est donc déjà cadreur et où j'ai dit
est ce que tu veux bien
filer un coup de main et ensuite quand
le concours a été fini on l'a posté en
ligne mais sur vimeo à l'époque j'avais
pas de compte youtube pour la montrer
aux potes et là c'est le drame
ça a été le cas en fait en vrai c'était
quand même quelques jours en fait ça
fait 80 les vues ou anna facile de
dépasser les cent mille vue assez vite
en fait un vrai 100 mille vue sur une
vie mais aux séries mais aux
personnalités en était pas pu tomber
dans ces même pas ma nombreux dans cette
équipe
bah c'est un peu après c'était la peur
quotidienne nationale
la presse quotidienne la reprise est en
effet un bref ça a pris et du coup là on
s'est dit ah beh waouh peut-être qu'on
pourrait allier l'expérience vidéo donc
avec une chaîne youtube parce que
youtube c'est plus viral que vimeo et
plus dans les pratiques on va dire et
l'expérience de la vulgarisation mais
sur des sujets qui sont un peu plus les
miens que je passe par l'ambition après
voilà et du coup c'est comme ça qu'en
septembre que toute la chaîne avec
barthélémy qui filme et toujours mais on
pourra encore c'est ça ma deuxième fille
et prenez-en pour vous maintenant oui
alors faut donc pour toi très bien et
c'est une question de l'uci or et c'est
à moi duquel logiciel utilise le tue
pour les dessins alors j'utilise pas du
tout un logiciel d'anim qui utilisent un
logiciel de storyboards pascal a battu
story board 2 et comme je suis à l'aise
dedans basset meilleur moyen pour aller
plus rapidement et en en gardant mes
marques une fois quelqu'un dit sans
commentaire vrai on pourrait essayer ce
que trois semaines du coup j'utilise un
logiciel qui s'appelle storyboard toon
boom pro et jean chéri là dessus avec un
email
adobe très bien voilà et et voilà c'est
j'utilise heures un stylet sur une
tablette avec un ordinateur et où tu
dire où tu as travaillé oui bah oui bah
je peux remercier le studio qui m'a
accueillie
donc parce qu'avant je travaillais chez
un studio qui s'appelle bobby peas qui
est vachement cool croyable série de
qualité koudouss bobby peas mais une
grosse partie de l'équipe de la semaine
est en effet chez bovi peas on a les cas
soc on a une super série qui s'appelle
vermine aussi d'autres séries encore à
venir donc je vous conseille vraiment
d'aller jeter un acquis social
et comme j'ai bossé pour eux ils me
l'ont été super sympa et m'ont laissé
travailler dans le studio donc pour
notre projet ce qui est rageant c'est
super sympa donc merci beaucoup beaucoup
pils ouais on a alors c'est pas une
question la stupide économique ce qu'il
dit cook a pris les cocos qui écoute qui
finit par bien que et on a couru ni
stupide qui fait un smiley comme ça
est-ce qu'il est question pour bart
est-ce qu'on a une passion pour
partition pour bar je crois pas en avant
il avait une wave c'était moi j'adhère
but inviolé les zones sûres pour des
vrais broyer les questions pour de bach
j'avais vu sur deux pour pour deux
barques vrai j'avais vu sur les réseaux
sociaux populaires tout cas qu'un
alignement des oui alors qu'ils aient
comme atos est tous d'accord répond déjà
à cela qu'ils aimeraient journée une
autre la question classique entre
guillemets bas depuis le début j'utilise
toujours le même appareil donc c'est un
canon 5d mark ii qui date un peu je
l'achetais en 2011 déjà d'occasion en
2019 donc il a bien vécu il ya des pixel
mort il a des boutons qui marchent plus
il y avait des gens qui me disent j'ai
essayé mon écran au regard donc oui j'ai
un jaj 5 aussi à disposition mais je
n'utilise pas pour la chaîne parce que
j'aime vraiment l'image du 5d c'est un
peu l'image de deux c'est une autre
histoire aussi les pixels
ah ouais ça donne quoi un opticien 56 mm
1,8
en plastique là le cannon qui est très
bien souvent un grande ouverture avec
quelques filtres voilà et sinon je suis
souvent sur un monopole ou un trépied
parfois à l'épaule est lancée récemment
acheté un autisme aussi grâce à vous les
types comme on va aller à tahiti comme
vous le savez où comme vous savez
peut-être pas est ce qu'on l'a annoncé
je sais plus y'a pas de secret non c'est
que avec le format des villes aux
détails que vous connaissez une question
d'ailleurs y at il d'autres villes aux
états qui moi c'est l'occasion d'y
répondre on a une dotation du cnc donc
on a pu faire
vienne et bratislava bratislava sort
très bientôt et on va à tahiti donc on a
fait un max d'économies sur les deux
premières destinations restent en très
peu de temps et on alors pas trop loin
pour pouvoir aller à tahiti ensuite avec
qui on a aussi trouvé des partenaires
mais il faut former de notre agent peur
on a investi bataille pour le coup avec
l'argent du cmec notre argent dans un an
ce mot pour pour avoir des belles images
de belles déambulation des beaux
paysages le smau c'est un angle très
large s'est stabilisé donc là on va
pouvoir faire les belles vidéos voyage
sur la plage / dvi medicom sortir la
corsa vacances
non pas du tout c'est beaucoup de
travail mais on a besoin de belles
images malgré tout
voilà je sais pas combien de temps on a
fait oui ça c'est une bonne question
peut-être complet aucun aucun chrono que
j'avais peut-être une occasion pour toi
barre tant qu'on est là où il demande
depuis quand tu travailles avec manon
est ce que t es ce que tu fais d'autres
vidéos à côté depuis quand je
travaillais comme un nom depuis le tout
début de la chaîne
donc comme maintenant expliquer tout à
l'heure on a commencé par un concours de
vidéos en dehors de la chaîne ça c'était
en 2009 et 2015
et voilà donc on a commencé en 2015 et
depuis j'ai fait presque toutes les
vidéos de la chaîne voit la part quand
je suis pas là aucun besoin de remplacer
ces exceptions mais en fait man on se
connaît depuis plus longtemps puisqu'on
a fait beaucoup de théâtre d'impro
ensemble on était à toulouse on s'est
rencontrés à la fac pour faire du
théâtre d'impro donc on s'est rencontré
en 2011
2011 est ce que je fais d'autres vidéos
à côté pas dans le youtube game on va
dire moi je suis opérateur caméra et je
bosse dans la publicité
voilà je suis opérateur caméra
spécialisée dans le ralenti le slow
motion
je suis opérateur caméra phantom on
appelle ça et donc je bosse sur des
publicités par exemple à semaine
prochaine j'ai une pub
comme je fais pas sur des clips aussi ou
des trucs comme ça et c'est mon vrai
métier pour moi youtube
c'est beaucoup d'implication etc mais
c'est passé la tige est entre guillemets
maintenant de plus en plus je peux te
rémunéré tout l'âme je commence
et ça c'est chouette et du coup ça
permet de professionnaliser le truc est
de faire des choses de plus en plus on
essaye en tout cas et ben les amis on
vous a gardé les questions suivantes
pour la deuxième poule 2 de faq vous
pouvez continuer à poser vos questions
je vais vous inviter à quitter le
plateau et je vais accueillir l'équipe
les deux équipes suivantes mercy west
ham y tient s'il ya un membre de
l'équipe qui veut bien me ramener une
bouteille j'ai presque fini la même et
après je vais sauter du coup je vais ap
ap ap hm je vais accueillir la suite
donc on va tout de suite recevoir les
membres de l'équipe iii pour s'affronter
sur la deuxième première manche vous me
suivez
nous avons tout d'abord mélanie coucou
mélanie ça va merci d'être ici installe
toi sur ce petit ben oui enfin joli
carré paie d'ailleurs toi tu branches
denis gratton le bouton je délire avril
c'est tout un symbole un noël c'est beau
j'adore tâches ministérielles
bon c'est gratuit alors mélanie tu veux
me présenter ta chaîne en
[Musique]
un petit
petites phrases donc la manie du cinéma
parle de cinéma mais sans pour autant
parler de film subtil des interviews des
making of est d'ailleurs peut-être envie
d'un mix est quelque chose de trop cool
qui arrive bientôt sur la chaîne à bata
web vidéo histoire demain
ouais je lui ai fait une interview de
boules est l'auteur de bd et il va dire
dedans pourquoi ils s'appellent boulet
les ex méga excusable abonnez vous allez
voir ça ça sort demain nous allons
accueillir aussi thomas salue tout
savoir
bienvenue à cette fois avec mélanie
thomas ce que tu veux nous piquer un
petit peu tâche est ce que tu fais sur
les internets wesh prend l'apéro
globalement il avait flambé émission de
libre antenne où globalement on utilise
ce prétexte de se rencontrer à plusieurs
et d'avoir des sujets de conversation
notamment de cul bordé cours tâche elle
s'appelle version version originale et
nous allons accueillir le dernier membre
de l'équipe
il s'agit de quotas c'est reparti alors
quand est ce que tu veux nous présente
est fâché qui est dur à présent sur
quatre se débrouiller alors on va un peu
bosser tout mais je suis fasciné par les
images et si possible bizarre et
j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi c'est
trop cool et la chaîne s'appelle à base
en 36 736 mais tout ça c'est écrit sur
votre gps de logo juste à côté de tata
depuis 2002 quand il est comme ça et
stylé et votre petit nom d' équipe
scellé
[Musique]
batman c'est trop long à écrire et
sortait mais j'aime beaucoup la petite
dédicace est lourd toujours l'humour
toujours présents sur la chaîne et nous
allons accueillir l'équipe cadre avec
premier membre lui si on est bien mais
tu sais j'ai failli s'évanouir
finalement après de coeur je vous
méprise
j'étais en train de poster une story sur
instagram extrêmement influent sur la
tête ça sera du meta direct ah oui c'est
bien comme ça ça va prouver aux gens que
c'est du live
mais oui c'est du lacroix qui attend ça
change de style et je fais tout est en
train de me parler moi présente-toi
juste et après comme ça pendant que les
enfants tran huy ont joué également je
m'appelle lucien men et ma chaîne
s'appelle lucien men et mayenne tu veux
la paix tient peu je veux la pitch est
un peu c'est tout simplement des
sketches de type humoristique aussi un
peu de court métrage un peu moins rigolo
mais un peu plus produit un peu plus
cinématographique et demain soir je fais
un live auquel tous les invités à
célébrer mes cent mille car toi tu es à
200000 moi je suis un peu ça fait un peu
plus d'un an donc cent mille suis
content c'est hyper cool c'est une belle
croissance
félicitations tu peux faire testory pour
prouver aux gens que tout vérifier sur
son instinct et nous allons accueillir
tout le flou mais voilà ok c'est
l'équipe des far et non pas d'accord ça
va trop bien j'avais fini c'est la
installe toi flaubert est ce que tu te
présenter pour les gens qui pètent et
bien sûr ils ont très peur de ce qu'on
appelle florent bernard voilà flaubert
sur internet un média sur lequel j'étais
présent il ya des années maintenant et
puis voilà je fais des
j'ai réalisé et scénarisé des trucs sur
golden moustache tuyaux beagle j'écris
sur une série qui s'appelait bloqué j'ai
un truc c'est le pitch en ce moment j'ai
une super le pitch est là le croit en
cours de baptiste lecaplain et j'ai un
podcast dans lequel tu viens dans le
prochain d'ailleurs qui s'intitule flot
de caste voilà décidément ces réseaux là
il s'agit du flot de caste la plus amère
et nous allons accueillir le dernier
membre de cette équipe mais pas des
moindres il s'agit de florence
florence qui présentait à cherré petite
phrase a montré on sait alors moi je
suis florence je suis en droit et du
coup je travaille bien son jeu m'a dit
qu'un pacte est très longtemps j'ai
patienté vidéo mais ça arrive bientôt et
notamment tu a particulièrement brillé
avec ta vidéo
j'avais gagné les pouces drôle de
l'année qu'il est bizarre d'y tuer parce
que le titre et le titre et pourquoi les
avocats de franges des monstres dans la
merde je trouve qu'une fois que la
question voilà ça c'est les jo allez on
va tous se posent là tu crois que je
rappais mais très rapidement les règles
pour ceux qui arrivent en cours
éventuellement et pour vous aussi
éventuellement donc je vais vous donner
à tour de rôle une question donc c'est
pas une épreuve de vitesse pour cette
manche aller buzzer ne sont pas actifs
pour l'instant donc vous allez avoir
chacun chaque équipe vautours une
question je vais vous donner trois
propositions il faudra me dire laquelle
est vrai ou laquelle est fausse en
fonction de la question c'est très
simple vous allez comprendre quand je
vais vous poser la question à base de
qcm un point si vous trouvez pas de pain
si vous trouvez pas évidemment au hockey
ce qu'il ya là non mes bougies en fait
et si à la fourrière un ex-aequo on sait
jamais là il y aura une question très
facile au buzzer pour vous départager
ok oui question buzzer vous allez vous
proposer
la caution l'humour donc le ca l
n'oubliez pas que si vous voulez poser
des questions dans la faq
enfin dans le chat pour la faq qu'il y
aura après entre sept manches et la
dernière n'hésitez pas à les questions
pour moi même si vous avez envie mais
aussi pour bart notre real ou pour lui
si les minutes notre dessinatrice vous
pouvez vous lâcher dans les commanderies
hier alors première question pour
l'équipe 3 c'est-à-dire la question 7
puisqu'elle continuera
c'est quoi une équipe l équipe d g pas
donner foi de mon équipe vous êtes les
flots regardez ça on est dans l'endroit
c'est si mignon écoute on essaye bon
j'aime bien racheté les tee-shirts ont
un petit creux de chartes avec un dessin
raté
n'hésitez pas vous avez alors le claquer
de ces propositions est fausse il existe
un homme qui a survécu aux deux bombes
atomiques au japon
réponse b on estime que la peste noire a
tué environ 10% de la population
européenne en cinq ans réponse c'est les
nazis faisait des expériences sur les bp
laquelle est fausse
vous avez tous là qui s'affiche en civil
de l'hérault non mais on a une vraie un
vrai plateau et tous est resté les
bénéfices non la bbc sûr vous allez tous
les deux et hawzi charles ensemble c'est
en partie en avoir mais on a des jeunes
à tous les deux visité auschwitz et moi
je me souviens pas d'avoir vu des photos
d'eux
j'ai fait des trucs pour sélectionner
les voir venir soit en terme
d'expérience est ce que parce qu'on peut
se sentant plus là on s'entend que vous
excusez moi juste de termes d'expérience
est-ce que c'est médicale générale
sociologique
quand elle fait des études c'est une
question qui importe donc du tout ça
peut être donc par exemple des experts
sur une baisse que ça peut être rien est
un peu la longe la dernière c'est à dire
les vrais j'hésite entre la première et
la seconde c'est la première est vrai je
voulais vue d'un épisode dax lot
t'es sûr que je pense que patrick on ne
peut pas se tromper patrick et moi en
fait je dirais que la deuxième est
fausse parce que ça laisse plus deviner
c'est pour ça que je pense que là c'est
le changement que c'est 50% passant
qu'ils à sion attendait donc on se met
d'accord parce qu'on est ok pour dire ah
bon donc c'est bien plus que ça en effet
c'est en trombe à ce que bon et c'est un
peu à la louche évidemment c'est entre
30 et 50% on estime la population
décimée eh bah 30 l'ebit d'april façon
l'homme qui a survécu aux deux bombes
atomiques au japon c'est assez fou en
effet comme histoire c'est je vais très
mal prononcé aussi je m'excuse susumu
hier à gucci
donc il était à hiroshima pour son
travail le 6 août 1945 qui vont ces
matrices sympa à la date anniversaire
bien jouer tes parents il a survécu
donc déjà à la fois pas de chance énorme
chance mais il a juste été très
gravement brûlé je crois ça va
franchement ça va
de fines et voilà c'est bon c'est comme
bronzer mais il est rentré chez lui donc
à nagasaki et un truc chez lui à
nagasaki est apparemment
bon à vérifier joue pas tous les détails
mais il me semble qu'il est retourné
travailler assez rapidement en mode
japon me suis pris une bombe atomique
sur la tête mais je vais travailler et
donc il s'est pris le 9 août la deuxième
il a aussi survécu mais je crois que sa
famille a été assez dessiné par les
cancers ses jambes
il est par contre elle est décédée
depuis mais je crois que très attendu et
les nazis faisait des expériences sur bb
b par exemple on pouvait voir un
témoignage de juifs déportés dans le
dernier film de claude lanzmann qui est
sorti les quatre soeurs et qui
d'ailleurs claude lanzmann qui est
décédé juste après la sortie de son film
aussi voilà bref donc donc c'est une
bonne réponse un projet bien souffler et
3,4 oui
laquelle de ces propositions est fausse
au moyen âge on jetait de l'huile
bouillante par dessus les châteaux forts
par dossier les remparts des châteaux
forts au moyen-âge ont jeté de la pwa
par dessus les remparts de châteaux
forts
la poisse est une substance noire
inflammables ok c'est un truc qui
m'énerve c'est un truc qui sert à faire
non c'est plutôt un truc qui sert à
accoler sens et un liant
un truc de joueurs et de l'enduit quoi
un enduit chercher au moyen âge ont jeté
du caca par dessus les remparts de
châteaux forts la caisse parce que kaka
c'est vrai à la manière des gilet jaune
contre le reste les cas 14
il ya une très belle photo qui a tourné
sur twitter avec une bouteille de pepsi
rempli de chiasse mais vraiment voilà
c'était le tweet très bon et donc si on
résume
il ya un quadragénaire énergie alors
qu'ils ont retrouvé il voulait des
pulsions plus moi j'en ai dit moi j'ai
des verts j'ai avec la fossella appuyé
ce que j'ai entendu à montbazon que le
nom car je ne fais pas invité alors ta
présence
que visiblement lui c'était trop chaud
trop cher aux charmilles donc c'est pour
ça qu'ils envoyaient plutôt de la merde
et et des restes de gens morts et tout
ça et pas trop cher alors six ans est de
fous non non c'est faux c'est bon allez
suivre on va valider la la quand même
pas oui c'est sa cellule c'est bien trop
précieux pour à l'époque mais pas là en
revanche on peut jeter tout le reste
la poisse est pas très compliqué à faire
me semble-t-il ce genre de la résine et
trucs comme ça pas très compliqué le
discours le plus long
non mais enfin way to tvq est donc un
peu partout un point pour l'équipe prend
un point pour l'équipe
carrasso mais je suis je suis accrochée
et canapés 3 laquelle de ces
propositions est vrai à la cataracte de
monet a transformé sa peinture b van
gogh était gaucher ce qui orientaient
les traits de sa peinture c'est toulouse
lautrec était atteint de nanisme et avec
des pinceaux spéciaux dont le manche
était plus long mais j'aime beaucoup m
c'était je crois je m'attaque était
petit mais pas moi je crois je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit atteint de nanisme
mais il était petit ça c'est certain il
a un très bel appartement un petit trois
pièces et tous ces manifestations c'est
plutôt quoi dire si c'est dingue non
c'est non c'est non résume ni pas là
mais bon pour le lot mais le marché
n'est aujourd'hui du loup est à même de
mener ça me paraîtrait logique qu'il
soit gaucher est ce que ça change
quelque chose
puis le coup du
anis mili baisse sans tableau il faut
pas dépasser les plus donnés mais la
cata il avait un truc à elle je loge et
c'est là la couleur c'est possible
effectivement il y ait un petit soucis
oculaires qui est non seulement
intéresse à percer ce qu'on met du coup
la transcription sa percée du continent
version 9 car finalement ce qui est
quand on pense à aaron n'oublie que par
le prisme de notre vision est aussi un
auteur quinquin lecteurs finalement de
nous sommes tributaires que de nos
émotions de notre perception c'est ce
qui fait que notre art et franche et non
pas seulement par notre conscience et
nos acquis évidemment mais aussi par
notre sensibilité au monde tel qu'il se
donne un nouveau jugement
bah là franchement oui et puis je suis
comme même si elle était fauché obligé
de dire vrai vu cette explication alors
pour la paix on voit la petite
explication donc mené en effet avait une
cataracte est donc alors monnaie donc
c'est l'impressionnisme c'est le truc de
peindre vraiment l'impression de la
lumière sur l'oeil est vraiment les
couleurs telles qu'on les voit et pas
dans les détails précis sentiment que le
voilà enfin vraiment l'impression que ça
te laisse coi et du coup comme ça vu à
évoluer petit à petit s'est fait opérer
s'est pas très bien passé et machin on
voit visiblement danse et la peinture
les couleurs changer et devenir de plus
en plus rouge et jaune à partir d'une
période que j'ai noté 1903 qui me pesait
plus qu'avec son sens et sa piste
pour la petite histoire vincent van gogh
n'est pas à gauche et j'ai totalement
inventés et toulouse lautrec était en
effet atteint de nanisme parce que il
avait une maladie génétique parce que
ses parents noble était cousin et et et
voilà ça l'empêché de développer saison
correctement mais il a jamais eu une
pince spéciaux d'où ta remarque
pertinente de noms mais je me suis dit
sur un malentendu ça peut passer
j'ai fait savoir que ça va être plus
être un petit
un petit caprice de la place de la
parlotte oui je mettrai les références
la remise du prix du court métrage bref
mais voulait donc c'est encore un poids
pour l'équipe 3 robin oui on avance à
son équipe de souffler picasso était
soupçonné d'avoir volé la joconde frida
kahlo a une liaison avec trotski dalli a
fait un caméo dans un film d'hitchcock
au [ __ ] c'est faux ça date à laquelle
la fosse técher de danica may laquelle
je dis j'ai dit la réponse est fausse il
faut se garder pour trouver à l'est pas
ce que je vais dire et d'un calot je
suis assez sûr que c'est vrai mais le
d'alice et c'est très crédible aussi un
espagnol avec des grandes moustaches ça
me dit rien après je veux pas mais c'est
un cadeau mais un caméo est évident que
les cellulaires de films aussi d'aller
voir récemment il est mort enfin relate
récemment dans les années 80 est mort
mais ils sont son contemporain temps
pour j'en ai vu un peu de hitchcock ou
c'est sûr il n'ya pas d'amis mais après
j'ai ouï la fin là c est l
le chien andalou et tyler ennis bunuel
dessinée avant d'avaler jamais entendu
pas mal
il ya un spectacle au parc astérix qui
s'appelle le vol de la joconde sages
fous lettres culture des autres cultures
on sait pas si elle sourit qu'est ce que
tu en penses que l'on perd sur deux non
non c'est trop on connaître l histoire
je pense en fait tu sais que la joconde
a été souvent dans la guerre a été sous
un lit c'est une histoire que tu connais
tu es en même temps qu'à ce que je me
permets dali dans un truc d'hitchcock
même si elle l'a inventé ça sorte de sas
en trouve nulle part pour que je sois
faux j'ai apprécié sa sait que trop bien
pour et de faux passé militaire
évocation c'était un petit un petit peu
plus quand il faisait plein de points un
pont qui conte cuisiner en fait il a
fait plein de petites fourberie comme ça
moi même fait douter je peux pas je peux
pas avoir confiance en ma culture je
suis clairement les absentes sur ce truc
de base me diraient ils enclenchent un
mais quitte en inventer un oncle s'est
fait plus j'avance que le a
voilà c'est tout ce que je dis dalli qui
fait un caméo dans une scop je trouve
que c'est ça s'invente ne savons plus
que picasso de l'averse pardon dans sa
servante moins que puel voulait la paix
vous dit tout
la grille j'ai envie de te suivre en
temps utile donc ce serait la faute ce
serait là ça attention à lui si on peut
faire confiance alors après l'arrêt de
sa responsabilité
non alors on va on va dire ah mais notez
bien chez vous moi j'veux pas excédé la
ce et est décédé seulement c'est m mais
puisque je m'étais jamais par cela eh
bien c'était là c'est ma mère que j'ai
totalement inventés du coup je suis
contente d'avancer alors qu'elle soit
était soupçonné d'avoir volé la joconde
directement pour toi ta colère donc le
jeu qu'on a été dérobée en 1911
picasso a été donc soupçonnèrent j'ai
pas dit c'est bon il a été interrogé par
la police ainsi qu'à paris nerfs parce
qu'apparemment le secrétaire
d'apollinaire vais voler des statuettes
antique et en avait revendu à picasso ou
qu'ils étaient voilà et il semblerait
que même apollinaire effet un peu prison
à cause de ça mais c'est pas la joconde
qui l'on doit le savoir
non c'est ton truc alors
le couple si je me trompe pas un vitrier
italien qui se fait choper trois ans
plus tard à florence en essayant de
revendre le tableau est plus à quel
cadeau à bien une liaison avec trotski
passionnés en 1937 mais assez brève et
dali n'a pas fait de cameo avec
hitchcock mais c'était assez crédible
parce que il est né en 1904 est mort en
1989 et du coq
il est né en 1899 est mort 1980 les gens
vous aider caméo dans aucune idée de 6e
sont jamais absolument pas côtoyé ou ce
n'est pas du prenais de la coke ça fait
2 4
donc on est un équipe croit donc savoir
si vous gagnez ton gun vous gagnez tout
court
équipe iii laquelle de ces propositions
est vrai les gaulois fabriquer des mini
noir n'a pu napoléon n'était pas petit
le père noël rouge et blanc a été créée
par coca cola est vrai la paix vraie
belle patate à travers le cameroun
samedi les verts et ceux qui l'ont mis
en route chemin je vais je sais que je
sais que ça c'est fait du père noël
était rouge avant enfin c'est pas coca
cola que les rouges l'ont déjà rouge
c'est sûr sûr sûr sûr les relations
c'est saint nicolas et le père mal sont
encore ça sent super mauvais ça sent le
truc qu'on croit tout ce qu'ils font des
médians fait que nadeau d'obélix alors
en fait le truc c'est que les menhirs je
crois que c'est assez commun dans le
monde
c'est en tout cas oui partout par
exemple saviez vous qui avez plus de
dolmens en corée du sud qu'en bretagne
oui mais taper quelque chose et voilà on
en apprend tous les jours
oui en fait c'est une légende urbaine
qui a été diffusée par ses adversaires
pour réduire sa réputation mais après le
truc c'est comme ça
après ça dépend ce montant paraît
qu'elle effraie les amis oui ben donc
c'est l'abbé que c'est l'abbé napoléon
je tiens à dire que le losc est aussi
fausse que l'ego de rigolos fabriquer
pas de menhirs c'est chaud non je pense
pas fâché potasse k par là moi je pense
que vraiment napoléon n'était pas je
suis en tout cas pas si petite ça tienne
la toile et auquel napoléon du coup oui
et non on a cette image me donnait ma
chaîne qui ils ont à la prison de casser
le dos d'ailleurs je crois non le 2
c'est qui ces genres le fils buback
sobhraj ce n'est pas du tout marché
portuaire voisine quoi je me sens qu'on
bat monfils est ce que ça fait c'est je
pense que c'est la baie et surtout je
crois que même ce genre de session en
toi-même 75 m quand même c'est pas cool
car j'aime la pluie réponse b napoléon
n'était pas aussi ses ébats une erreur
et ils ont raison
un point technique désolé c'est pas
grave l'essentiel vous avez c'était moi
je sais pas vous mais donc alors donc
vous avez vous avez bien le point les
goulots fabriquer pas du tout des
menhirs ça c'est avancer c'est c'est
complètement ont pré historique
enfin ces genres néolithique d'accord et
c'est entre 7000 agents et 3 300 avant
ce câble deuxième place en cours si
szczesny et les gaulois c est enfin plus
legolas avant que rien de ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que les gaulois sont arrivés
dans une région meublé du coup ils ont
pris 1,21 me plaît et donc c'est plutôt
à partir du vème siècle avant en europe
pour l'europe même si c'est plein de top
différents alors c'est un peu compliqué
de dater mais bon bref ils fabriquent et
pas les manières ça c'est où le cliché
est assez hauts revenus
oui napoléon n'était pas
mais de taille absolument moyenne ça
c'est une légende urbaine en effet et
combien 70 74
donc je vais pas y aller en effet le
père noël rouge et blanc il n'a pas été
créée par coca cola mais de très
popularisé par quoi quoi et ça aussi
c'est un peu une simple un la gamme mais
voilà une leçon que vous avez deux
points ça veut dire que vous avez gagné
mais je vous propose deux ans pour le
sport vous posez votre dernière question
c'est le relais alors équipe 4
peut-être que vous partiez avec panache
quand même laquelle de ces propositions
est fausse le droit de cuissage est un
mythe au xviie siècle on pouvait être
condamné pour un tel sens sexuel
donc le droit tu connais nora et pour
moi ça des études qui vous coûter un
bras c'est le moment de montrer un en
grèce antique les femmes vierges de plus
de 40 ans était convertie en prêtresse
laquelle chose on a vraiment des plus
durs que vous parce que tout à l'heure
il est question le
laquelle est là qu'elle est fausse le
produit sa mise à la grippe le droit est
un mythe c'est faux mais est ce qu on
pouvait être condamné pour impuissance
sexuelle est ce que ça vaut prendre '
est-ce que en grèce antique les femmes à
sa méthode patriarcat et condamner les
aider mais qui bandent passerait plutôt
les meufs qui seraient condamnés
ouais j'en ris nom qui n'empêche pas ben
dingue genre un big band passé la meuf
que tu prends pas le ghana temps ils
disent pas on pouvait être condamné pour
un non comment sinon c'est là peut-être
oui alors c'est vrai que je peux
préciser la question je parle de
l'impuissance masculine
d'accord je serais surpris mais
peut-être en bien du coup qu'on est con
et plus elle soit pour une fois plus des
mecs que les meufs qu'être inquiet de
genre de trucs ouais mais le droit de
cuissage c'est un mythe
les gars c'est plus sympa on sait qu'en
gagnant on aide les gens c'est quand
même un peu plus à paris et j'ai dit
c'est une maj de droit qui parle je veux
pas engager la réputation non plus
retard a donc sage c'était un mythe
hockey bien sûr sur des jeux vidéo qui
demandent donc je suis moins qu'avec toi
sur ce sujet doivent se rendre en grèce
antique les femmes vierges de plus de 40
ans était convertie en prêtresse j'ai
l'impression que c'est vrai ouais au
besoin on n'est plus dans le patriarcat
de l'histoire bah ouais c'est la pesée
qui est faut sentir sur la tournée ou
super ou au dessus donc les gagnants
alors revoter b mais moi je disais c'est
anne on échange des coups de poing
c'est qu'elle est maintenant que c'est
pour partir avec panache ou avec des
fêtes ou non violé
quel est votre
le label ab ouais oui bien sûr vous
voulez et c'était la scea [ __ ] donc à
chaque fois c'était là c'est la fosse
bah ouais mais je fais exprès en fait
parce que tu peu de terrain mais on a dû
plusieurs fois là ses cheveux par petit
bout d'chou s'agitera sel c'est un mythe
en effet vous pouvez lire à ce propos
[Musique]
l'ouvragé d'alain bourreau qui est
historien le droit de cuissage la
fabrication d'un mythe 13e 20e siècle
mais vous devez le demander avec eux
l'élève qui tombe parce que c'est donc
se prononcer hyper intéressant mais je
reconnais pas avoir lu seulement un
résumé voilà et et au xviie siècle
donc il existait avant des tribunaux
pour impuissance masculine mais alors il
ya un milliard de dhs étape d'arriver à
la condamnation mais on connaît un cas
où le cas du marquis de langeais en 1657
qui s'est fait condamner pour
impuissance mais alors c'est vraiment
plein d'étapes genre d'erreur c'est le
motif c'est une bande pas donc tu peux
pas faire d'enfant à ta femme hors
contrat de m
machin alors que cela est bon dans un
beurre il ya des moyens de trouver des
solutions en brèves et un peu
d'imagination on peut dire pour te
porter plainte quand son mari donc
d'abord je crois j'ai noté dans que les
diablos oui alors d'abord le mari doit
avouer il faut quand même qu'ils disent
est vrai je ne peux pas mais en même
temps si l'on pas l'enfant pendant super
longtemps
oui bah écoute apparemment un cas
existent en tout cas ensuite il faut que
cela j'aime bien il faut récolter des
témoignages des proches
c'est à dire les voisins les unit c'est
vrai qu'ils vont pas aux trottoirs mais
plus comme l'accusé dans la cour
ses cris on a été surpris nous on l'a
toujours vu bonbons à contre jour et
comme baissiers quoi la valeur
on est des bancs des biens ayant comme
l'avait demandé dans la rue enfin je
sais pas ensuite en impose qu elle une
vie commune de 3 en coupe pour être sûr
commencer ne bande pas d'étape sur
l'épreuve finale et profite à la passe
de trois ans il yal'expérience expert
médical devant des médecins où le couple
doit coucher
merci monsieur n'a pas abordé ce qui est
assez probable sexualité normale
je lui demande de baiser devant moi
perso je n'aime pas qu'on voyait n'était
pas elle s'entoure il mais est ce que
monsieur tout simplement pas c'est juste
pas aimé sa femme parce qu'à ma
connaissance ici c est alors bondé avec
toutes les voisines en bus pour aller
plus loin apparemment l'homme du coup
enfin la femme à droite sur marié
l'homme n'a pas droit de se remarier
tant qu'elle n'est pas morte et de
l'huître a encore tué 2 clics
il a réussi a faim il a pour lui deux
maîtresses avec visiblement ils
vendaient bien et l'a réussi à faire
annuler un truc et se remarier 3 bravo
l'ic3 merci l'équipe théâtre d'avoir été
aussi fair-play paris pour ce petit
hôtel
ouais je les ai invités gentiment
plateau et je vous dirai de revenir
twitter pour la finale et de revenir
tout à l'heure pour le gros au revoir le
prix final coup là ouais non je ne
devrais pas faire ça et donc je vous
invite à quitter plateau et je vais
recevoir tout de suite lulu 6e pour le
retour de la faq ni poser vos questions
dans le chatte dans la merci les amis
non j'ai pas vu un punching bag de
sperme et de chaque accouchement
on n'était pas mauvais en attendant
réussi je vous propose règlement of
recoucou je t'en fais pas de bisou mais
je pense que ça va aller mais enfin
j'aime tellement toujours te faire des
bisous que l'otan envoie donc au cas où
certains emprunts route je vous
représente une lucie qui est donc
l'immuno dessinatrice qui a animé les
deux derniers épisodes animés que vous
allez voir sur la chaîne donc la drogue
des nazis et le cannibalisme si vous les
avez pas encore vu vous avez tellement
de chance vous avez un truc génial à
découvrir puis tiendra bien pour le voir
pour la première fois à prétention mais
carré porte et tu bosse tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours elle n'a
pas d'avenir d'un ton qui n'a pas la
fraîcheur du premier regard mais en est
ce petit plaisir quand même de le on est
allé j'étais invité une master class au
forum des images avec patrick boos et
lucie était dans la salle et l'on
diffusé et on a le plaisir de le voir
diffuser avec un public
iriez en direct par de réaction vraiment
l'adresse est très agréable et on va
accueillir par tous il est presque il
est prêt peut-être pas je prépare un qui
n'est quand même pas où elle va
commencer à répondre à des questions
toutes les deux oui oui tout à fait mais
voilà elle va me voilà
et voici marque donc un petit problème
au dos micro notre real et clever de
chaînes partenaires voilà depuis le
début de la chaîne est-ce qu'on répondra
aux questions tu veux non je le fais si
tu veux en fait cette stèle il les a
sortis tous à flaubert j'ai peur que
tout à l'heure en besoin sa saveur
guingamp je vais les poser de très
délicatement pendant combien les
questions éternelles maxime lambert nous
demande
aura-t-il une rediffusion
de ce live live sera disponible sur la
chaîne fait l'effort pratique c'est pas
pratique
alors j'ai une question une double
question qui a été posée donc par cani
blayaise à 18h05 voyez on est précis qui
dit est ce que tu as trouvé un poste
suite à ta thèse et ça rejoint une
question qu'on est sur twitter déposée
par fils de pub et qui disait qu'elle
porte la thèse tout bretelles pour la
suite
alors c'est une très bonne question j'ai
pas trouvé de poste parce que je n'ai
pas cherché tout simplement et je me
destine pas la recherche parce que
maintenant je vis de la chaîne youtube
c'est mon travail je suis hyper contente
de faire ça et c'est très difficile de
trouver du travail dans la recherche
mais c'est même pas par défaut en fait
c'est parce que le jeu j'adorerais très
bon cette activité donc j'ai ma thèse
c'est très cool parce que ça permet
d'avoir un petit background valorisant
ça me permettra peut-être éventuellement
plus tard de broc cycle et si besoin est
mais j'ai même pas demandé la
qualification aux cmu c'est qualif qu'on
doit avoir pour pouvoir postuler au
maître de conférences je n'ai même pas
fait ça parce que je vis de la chaîne je
suis très content de faire sa jupe ont
eu tort autre chose
voilà la bonne question donc on va
trancher une question pour vous aussi
d'abord une question pour vous mais y
at-il une vidéo réalisée mais j'avais
posté et si oui pourquoi de cst 57 assez
simple y en a pas on a toujours réalisé
était jusqu'au bout
dockers précis que ça c'est très
décevant non c'est vrai nom est allé
jusqu'au bout à chaque fois et qui des
fois peut-être en posséder je veux bien
mais en fait que tu les remette à
l'instant de paix parce qu'ils vont
faire bouger la table car ça va là en
fait d'accord je sais mais c'est qu'ils
vont faire bouger avec les buzzer ça va
gicler de pars toujours bien ok ouais
bah j'avais une question donc elle était
posée pas tac tac tac c'est mieux de
dire le nom des gens je trouve c'est
plus un choix cet été donc c'était
julien merci julien la question c'est
quoi c'est quoi ta vidéo préférés sur la
chaîne
manon ta propre vidéo sur ta prochaine
elle préfère dur de répondre à ça ouais
faut pas avoir une vidéo préférés j'ai
je suis très très heureuse de faire les
dessins animés avec lui c'est maintenant
c'est très plaisant
moi je le trouve trop bien mais en plus
je peux me permettre de dire je les
trouve trop bien parce que j'ai donc je
suis pas c'est pas comme si c'était ma
vidéo d'habitude j'ai un peu de mal à
faire reste excellent higher education
sur ces vidéos est ce que ça va être une
série alors j'y reviens mais du coup du
coup je dors ce café contente et sur les
vidéos les autres sites
alors je pense que la vidéo de pourquoi
les statuts ont des petits pénis elle me
plait bien parce que je trouve que
l'exercice de vulgarisation et pas mal
rempli entre la question
cette intrigue un peu la réponse avec du
contenu mais c'est un peu drôle aussi
voilà et sinon cela en vrai les bons
souvenirs de tendresse tout simplement
mais c'est vrai en plus c'est non mais
c'est vrai les bons moments où les trucs
comme ça les voyages aussi évidemment
c'était cool même si c'est intense vague
ans mais c'est pas forcément
enfin c'est pour ça que j'en ai que
j'affectionne plus que d'autres alors
que c'est pas forcément les meilleurs et
du coup la deuxième question est ce que
le est ce que là alors les dessins sont
voués à continuer à exploiter
on aimerait très très fort continuent
hélas pour l'instant lui si tu m'as fait
un tarif d'amis plus que d'amis puisque
nous sommes puisque des amis dans cette
mélasse of death ray wang et du coup
j'ai payé avec mes petits sutout
personnel elle m'a fait un prix d'ami
mais ça reste cher et surtout si je veux
la payer avec des vrais cacher sa femme
étant ce qu il faudrait il faudrait
débourser à peu près mais c'est à peu
près de 1500 et 2500 une vidéo pour une
vidéo d'après ce que je peux faire pour
l'instant
et donc on va essayer trop des
financements pour rendre pérenne le truc
merci très fort à ceux qui soutiennent
déjà un peu sur steam ou enfin beaucoup
d'ailleurs vous soutenir beaucoup mais
ça super un pays mois et le 6 mai mais
c'est trop génial que ça y est là parce
que personne n'était même pas
envisageable
on peut évidemment pas passer trois
semaines sur chaque vidéo parce que sur
la précédente mais en faisant un tout
petit tout petit tout petit plus donc on
va essayer d'aller voir du côté du cnc
peut-être ou des choses comme ça
éventuellement si on a une réflexion là
dessus d'ailleurs du cnc alors j'ai dit
steph 0 qui dit c'est la mafia du cnc de
youtube qui s'amusent à vous et à
proposer et ben est donc alors pour être
un peu plus des mafieux du cnc et
réclamer plus d'argent pour juste faire
des grosses soirées et nous les mettre
dans les poches et pas du tout faire ces
projets est belle vidéo
on va essayer de redemander donc une
aide il faut qu'on s'occupe de monter le
dossier mais tous mais qui est du coût
serait dédiée aux salaires de pouvoir
faire une série du terrassement mais si
ça marche pas parce qu'on sait pas si on
l'aura peut-être qu'on se tend entre un
kickstarter l'enverra vous êtes chauds
pour certains voient là juste pour dire
le cncc une public
donc elle est accessible absolument tout
le monde donc si vous voulez de l'argent
du sensei a aucun souci mais il ya des
critères quand même un montant proche de
taille deux chaînes oui voilà deux
tailles de chaînes des classes les open
tout le monde enfin si vous le milliard
de vidéos plus incertain oui bien sûr
mais ce qui est donc ce n'est pas 100%
ouvert à tout le monde mais par contre
c'est dit ouais c'est l'argent public et
sert à les sous qui sont pris du cnc
s'est pas directement sur les impôts
tongs c'est sa toxine indiqué de signer
de netflix et de la taxe youtube
quant au web voilà donc et bah enfin par
ailleurs
parce que c'est cool que de l'argent
public pour soutenir la création en
france et qu'on reconnaisse notre taf
mais mais bref voilà c'est pas dit qu'on
l'ait donc on ces facteurs les îles
voilà si j'adhère peut-être de geek
starter n'hésitait pas à nous dire si
vous seriez juste aoc ça vous en
tiendrai pas du tout on se rend pas trop
compte mais c'est un fait mais bon vous
avez l'air d'aimer les épisodes mais
évidemment tout le monde va forcément
participé dont on aimerait en premier et
c'est d'avoir les les aides et si on les
affronte rate et rappelle à votre
question pour lui si donc ces phares à l
oubli 10 à 18 heures si ce qui te
demandes comment pouvons-nous entrer en
contact avec la dessinatrice
je suppose que c'est toi pour lui
proposer un projet qui en ring inférieur
à 3 et bien par mail j'imagine que c'est
encore un moyen de communication qui
marche bien c'est juste bas mon pseudo
donc les menus @ gmail point com il faut
peut-être que tu les payes ton pseudo
il est pas marquer quelques points 6
passes et à leur santé mais elle elle
les pélamourgues est réel
une 1re balle gmail.com mois sur un
sacré en gros boss sur un tacle trop
court et sinon instagram tout à fait
avec les contacts j'essaye j'essaye
et oui voilà les moyens techniques aussi
avec le facebook j la magie vais pas
trop du coup le meilleur moyen de
contact et c'est vraiment les mails et
instagram et je suis tout ouïe
juste pour qu'ils arrêtent flou des donc
l'archéonaute on t'a vu marquer notre
donc les oui mais se dit tu vas voir il
dit c'est pas une question mais je
voulais absolument félicité limoux pour
ses animations magnifique et brille
manon pour savoir qui colle parfaitement
merci voilà vous permettez faut décevoir
c'est vrai qu'il continue la digue
beaucoup de fois à quand la fin
donc moi j'ai ressenti beaucoup de fois
le compliment et et j'en profite aussi
parce que donc on est tous les trois sur
les clips de c'est une autre histoire
qu'on n'a peut-être pas expliqué trop la
répartition des tâches mais du coup moi
j'écris je présente comme vous savez et
je monte les vidéos bart et à la caméra
l'uci fait les dessins et nous avons
aussi aux thèmes dont vous entendez la
musique depuis le début du live qui fait
des morceaux pour nous qui a fait le
super remix de breaking bad sur le
dernier épisode drogue et nasik
et vous pouvez aller voir son sort vinci
est donc nous a fait le morceau exprès
il nous en a fait plein au jugement de
un peu ce que je veux pour le truc ça
fait vraiment l'identité de la chaîne
aussi donc on le remercie aussi derrière
votre écran
deux questions une maison que j'en ai
posé beaucoup tu peux y aller il ya
copains du web amende est ce qu il a vu
que j'avais sens belle excuse est la
question
nom de dieu elle porte quoi manon sur le
téton j'ai aimé la tête de copains sur
monte et on sait sont très jolie pin
c'est trop beau c'est comme ça vous le
voyez mais si vous ouvrez sur les
missions de marzouki et on regarde et on
appris de ça dérape
j'en ai une autre après je te lâche et
on a shared ski lucas qui demande à
quand votre passage sur le nexus 6 et by
the border à l'équipe alors excessive
on a discuté avec le capitaine mais
plusieurs trucs déjà à eux ils ont
énormément de boulot avec l'or avec
laure kickstarter là qui a bien marché
et et surtout il m'a demandé de lire un
livre de science fiction de 800 pages
j'ai commencé en mai dernier n'arrive
pas à lire ce livre donc il me reste
deux cents fois je crois maintenant ça
commence à devenir bien f1 voilà donc
quand j'aurai fini de lire ce livre ont
par la suite se pencher sur la colonne
qui eux aussi sont très ils sont très
occupés mais ça viendra promis une ou
deux cette édition non moi j'en ai
encore quelques-unes faire des petits
bisous sinon et peut-être faire venir
est ce que maintenant parce que fini
s'est bien installé dans sa nouvelle
colocation oui je leur fais des coûts si
je mets regard de l'accusé
dernière alors elle est un peu faute que
tu pourras peut-être rebondir c'est
quelqu'un sait pourquoi la vidéo sur la
drogue at elle été supprimée vidéo sur
la drogue lors de la seconde guerre
mondiale at elle été supprimée a été en
fait le système de la démonétisation sur
youtube c'est principalement les
mots-clés problématique entre guillemets
qui font que le robot les détecte et
l'idée c'est qu'il ya des annonceurs qui
veulent pas être mis sur certains types
de vidéos et donc forcément drogue nazis
c'est pas forcément hyper engageant pour
certains annonceurs mais du coup ce
qu'on a fait c'est que j'ai demandé une
vérification manuelle
ça a été remis et en plus relativement
vite c'est par rapport à d'autres fois
donc on n'a pas trop trop perdu je passe
avoue duré quelques heures et la
précédente sur la masturbation du jeune
prêtre
elle est revenue en une heure la
monétisation d'exécuter banques
pour l'instant on est un peu béni la
monétisation parce qu'on va pas se
mentir on joue un peu avec le feu là
dessus mais c'est un joyau que les kits
rigueur le truc est une âme une fois
qu'ils voient à baisser de la
vulgarisation et c'est pas juste bras
que de la drogue
ouais mais je pense que ce que savent
pas forcément tout le monde aussi même
moi je lui ai appris ans dans la chaîne
c'est que en fait
youtube mais beaucoup plus en avant des
vidéos qui sont monétiser alors j'arrive
pas à savoir si c'est vrai ou pas je dis
j'ai en fait je disais ça et au space -
dinan ouais alors youtube dit non mais
si clairement pour de vrai dire je ne
sais pas la dernière fois sur celle du
prêtre tué la dernière fois sur celle du
prêtre en effet elle a vraiment explosé
à cette sortie forcément c'est plus ta
clique aussi ça fait un truc comme 10000
15000 ça a été des monétiser enfin à
chaque heure dix mille 15000 saadi
démoniser vraiment j'ai vu le creux j'ai
demandé en une heure ces revues et pour
c'est reparti donc c'est peut-être un
gros hasard mais là ça cause ça collait
bien à voir mais ça n'est peut-être pas
liés il fut j'ai une question pour bart
oui de bart caillou vidéo tu es la
première personne que je vois qui porte
le même prénom que moi et en plus on
fait le même métier à un point
d'exclamation
c'est une exclamation pour parfait alors
voilà media markt et questions pour bart
du coup je le transmets qu'est ce que tu
vas les couleurs espèce de complexe les
barthes c'est que on croise très
rarement des barthélémy où quand on est
tous les deux dans une pièce il ya comme
un espèce de réflexe effet la jolie la
rencontre à leur compte en effet dix et
enfin un autre ouais d'accord très bien
des juifs un câlin est-ce que vous avez
des dernières questions pas c'est notre
finale
moi j'ai fait le tour j'avais noté des
questions intéressantes
oh c'est gentil pour eux alors pour
faire rentrer les deux équipes gagnantes
à savoir l'équipe 1 et l'équipe iii si
ma mémoire est bonne et nous on va
sortir et je vous fais un gros bisou
merci très fort pour le travail que vous
alliez la chaîne en tout cas ça vous
mettrez on se retrouve pour le final la
mairie à toute attente alors eh bien
sans plus tarder s'ils sont équipés on
va faire rentrer l'équipe 1 est ce
qu'ils sont prêts c'était qui j'ai pu
les petites sociétés thé au lait à et
jean baptiste
ils sont prêts ou jouer à meubler et
sont prêts je t'en prie
oui atheos équipe en avant meubler un
petit peu du coup votre nom d' équipe
c'est encore au titre elle encore
expliqué que le suisse qui a eu cette
idée
c'était beau c'était vous fait que ces
pratiques il est ce qu'il ya des membres
de l'équipe iv qui sont déjà prêts oui
ils sont tous prêts à bas ils ont qu'à
venir alors c'est un monde ailleurs cnrs
approuve la fpjq a d'ailleurs c'est
l'effet qu'il croise un baiia c'est vrai
et yahvé ton
exact exact alors et résister aux roues
alors on va faire un test juste
fonctionnalités du beurre
gfr alors non les amis parce que vous
avez posé vous allez en faire trop j'ai
vraiment l'impression d'être passé ok ok
ok ok parce que ici ils ont besoin
premier le buzzer et des actuels alors
c'est la finale alors oui donc je vais
expliquer vous l'expliquer c'est les
plus indisciplinés qui ont gagné quoi
mais on va ramasser ces rumeurs mais
mais c'est pas dans la nature les a
c'est sur le sol enfin les
protestataires près tout c'est à dire tu
es hashtag on est passé au bord de l'eau
alors je vous explique la règle et en
feuilles fruits côté un petit peu parce
que sinon vous allez voir c'est très
petit donc c'est une finale l'histoire
ou skyblog
alors je vais vous donner une citation
fortement écoutez c'est quoi ce que je
vais vous donner leur temps c'est la
personne la plus à la majo de l'internet
alors indiqué blog c'est
non mais 30 gare et pas voilà c'est un
c'est un blog de ses journaux intimes
quand on était au lycée en passant pas
des journaux intimes et des blogs où on
écrivait des grandes phrases
philosophiques un peu nunuche site situé
au quai d tu vois des trucs de collège
ou de lycée où tu mettais des images
avec des choeurs et tu disais tu
racontes on a juste avec kitty moi j'ai
toujours le mien je prenne un peu parce
que voilà en fait c'était que des
phrases de pseudo dit peux tu vois où tu
disais tu mettais des citations
poétiques de galles et alors tu as
raison il y avait plein de tout est
plein de types de skyblog mais quand on
pense à sky blog on pense vous êtes
d'accord avec moi au passage journal
intime sur internet oui c est souvent en
plus il y avait des couleurs de partout
on écrivait les oeufs avec des
paillettes ou vevo skyblog aujourd'hui
on a ouverte aux pitots notre skyblog
aujourd'hui c'est juan stella topito 2-3
x pense qu'elle est reprise à vittel a
ouvert aujourd'hui et il l'a placé alors
donc vous êtes je vais vous donner une
citation les enfants je vais vous donner
une citation vous allez devoir me dire
si c'est l'histoire ou skyblog inquiète
tout va bien les uns mais je vois que tu
es prête en effet 6 alors si ces
histoires ça peut être ça peut être un
philosophe ça peut être un personnage
historique ça peut être extrait d'une
dune oeuvres de littérature au caire
c'est à la rapidité mais c'est moi qui
active le buzzer pour poser donc voilà
donc je vais finir ma phrase et l'or est
lancé le buzzer parce que sinon vous
allez buzz et avant que ça se termine
vous me suivez
celui qui buzze les copains les copains
celui qui buzz et qui donne la réponse
soir ce qui donne la réponse qu'ils se
trompent ses poings pour l'autre équipe
alors la parade j'espère qu'ils en a qui
vont être au taquet pour compter les
points puisque j'ai patron peu en fin de
compte ouais ya trois ans roma 0 du coup
pour le hadj si donc si vous présentez
ces points notre équipe si c'est une
citation historique et par un skyblog je
donne deux points
si l'un d'entre vous me trouve qui a dit
ça d'accord mais c'est hyper dur de
trouver mais peut-être vous peut-être
vous connaissez la citation non nous il
n'y a pas de perte de points mais vous
me donnez par équipes une proposition
ok mais si on trouve des skyblogs alors
si tu arrives à trouver une mine ou du
31 c est vraiment très très très très
très fort mais ok ça va ouais alors pour
faire très simple vous me dites skyblog
ou parce qu'ibm ok ok j'aime bien cette
règle est sur les rangs mais du coup
cela je vais viser les jambes à sa table
d'hôte deux fessées les à la plus primée
peut-être qu'elle rate une balle arrêtée
- c'est vrai que c'est pas très
réglementaire tout ça voilà
mais si vous faisiez trop vite trop vite
et trop vite et vous vous plantez toute
façon vous filer le point j'espère
pouvoir donc maintenant cette équipe qui
s'est collé à l'essence au hockey vous
êtes prêts ouais attention je balance la
première elle a promis du coup j'ai fait
un exemple se faire des sensations je
fais un exemple si je vous dis pic pic
et colégram ça va non mais j'ai pas
compris pourquoi situation comment ça se
fait que vous soyez le premier ou la
faculté dans la finesse c'est un débat
prévu que théo que ne trompe pas les
laisser là vous êtes prêts ouais
est-ce que vous êtes prêts oui ok c'est
parti alors comme c'est bon pour semer
le trouble je vais le dire comme ça
nul n'est méchant volontairement le
clapot web est horrible je propose à la
russie si elle m'entend que je le dise à
l'oral et qu'il affiche vraiment
qu'après puisque de toute façon
ouais de toute façon ils vont buzz est
tout de suite est ok alors vous êtes
prêts attention on ne fait pas toujours
ce que l'on veut j'ai pas lancer le
buzzer est ok c'est bien ça coûte ici
c'est bien pratique vous laissez moi
finir vous savez même pas vous avez bien
entendu la fac c'est parce que l'on veut
on ne fait pas toujours ce que l'on veut
mais on est toujours responsable de ce
que l'on fait albaugh a pu temps à temps
il a dit alors j'arrête parce que le
groupe 'a skyblog il a deux disques
c'était sartre en mer devant la bourse
c'était histoire
non mais alors qu'une autre c'est la
faux nez on est tous fatigués mais du
coup d'enquêtés buzz et moi invités à
écouter la phrase je dis ça je dis rien
c'est tout c'est qu'on ne sait pas
du coup peut-être moins peser moins vite
mais écoutez ouais vous êtes prêts oui
peu de neurones vous êtes prêts le
bonheur dans le mariage est uniquement
une question de chance
du coup les regrette pas parce qu'une de
quoi le premier radar le mariage est
uniquement une question de chance à la
saison c'est la toile un truc de
rapidité du coup soient embêtés 15 ans
c'est en effet une phrase d'histoire et
qui vous avez droit à une proposition
proposition une proposition au jeu
celui-ci ça c'est le bonheur à paris
maria est ce que la santé sont très
pessimistes
très pessimiste au matin pourquoi passer
en procès sont des collines moi je
verrais bien un petit proust le bon soit
il parle de mariage après je suis pas
très calé en dit vous savez pas proust
que ce serait marivaux non plus bon
c'est hyper dur en vrai de trouver cet
extrait de orgueil et préjugés de jane
fostin sommes passés en quoi pour cette
équipe qui est de cette annonce donc
vous êtes un patron pas vous êtes prêt
2004 on me sommet pour toi à ne plus
aimer quelqu'un on se met à aimer
quelqu'un d'autre je ne mâche pas ses
mots il n'a pas marqué une seule fois on
va faire un test après skyblog attentes
et aux participants
tu connais le choix de construire l'iss
c'est bien ce style blog c'est en effet
le skyblog est joué
et je vais vous donner alors ces deux
view mélancolie je fais un test deux
heures pour eux pour voir voilà super
mais en fait il faut appuyer avec la
main c'est comme ça attention talent
est-ce que vous êtes prêts beaucoup de
moi est-ce que vous êtes prêts deviens
ce que tu es et bien je laisse rêveur
histoire ouais et marc aurèle c'est en
effet l'histoire et ce n'est pas marc
ovale socrates s'est passé au crac
c'était une fête l'aval de ses parents
si tu lis de manière débit louis
defrasnes de philosophes ont tiré du
skyblog ayant bien ce que tu es des
phrases est ce que est ce que c'est une
ligne des phrases de skyblog hyper
sérieusement ça peut paraître de
fraudeurs j'ai décidé pour plat vous
sinon ça donne la réponse de toutes les
merdes a même une façon plus voilà
attention vous des prêts on a dû te dire
qu'il faut réussir dans la vie
moi je te dis qu'il faut vivre c'est la
plus grande réussite
moi je pense que le style blog - c'est
un skyblog un froid pour cette équipe
cgm 22 kame vous êtes prêts attention
ces 2 2 juste contre d'accord je sais
pas du tout encore en tête
mais quand résidence par d'imaginer ce
qu'on avait oui oui c'est bon ok ils ont
le coran qu'ils nous diront après
attention aux prêts non parce par toi
même je vais etc moi je dirais quand tu
attends que ça viendrait coupat quand on
découvre donc je prends cette réponse et
c'est là que c'est comment tu veux donc
là ça fait un point pour la bonne
réponse
histoire de deux points pour quand donc
là je pense que nous avons gagné enfin
bon attention vraie la seule façon
d'être heureux c'est d'aimer souffrir à
lorient il ya un pied on pense on pense
tous les blogs oui ok mais il ya un
délire comme quoi ça peut être y
figurent mais aller au stade et bien non
c'est hyper intello comme 3 ça même si
ça fait maintenant trois pas il a tout
compris
je veux dire moi je dis que c'est
peut-être choisir j'ai l'impression
bourré c'est de votre faute on va dire
histoire et c'est dans ce cas de séisme
voilà c'est prêt donc c'est très profond
c'est un point pour notre équipe vous
êtes prêts l'imagination est plus
importante que la connaissance
l'histoire et c'est une fine bravo aux
caisses ans dur ok année
moi c'est bon vous êtes prêts attention
c'est plus le score vous êtes pressée
elle soit assez serré parce que on est
en attention c'est dommage qu'on le
sache pour autant que les bras des
maires sont fait de tendresse les
enfants et dorment profondément lu le
script sa pub de maman ça pue le de
maman franchement si mes histoires très
bon cinéma des maires de bluff annoncé
qu'ils allaient moi je moi je vais
skyblog ça vraiment le truc c'est que
c'est mignon mais faire une liste herman
je dirais que ces valeurs au pied son
honneur est sauf et je suis reçue
caution c'est votre réponse quel boulet
et bien c'est historique c'est pas ça ok
où est alors dans ce cas là ça va être
galère rousseau mais je suis peut-être
passer à l'étape en saut et vous une
proposition attention parce que je vais
prendre la première et comme tout à
l'heure a dit pascal ouais j'ai fait ça
intéressait pas parce qu'elle sait
victor hugo dans les misérables
vous êtes prêts c'est aussi au travers
des épreuves de la vie que l'on re
découvre l'essentiel attentes autant
c'est aussi au travers des épreuves de
la vie que l'on redécouvre l'essentiel
n'est pas quoi je pense c'est un skyblog
attention vous êtes prêts et c'est la
dernière d'ailleurs inscrit ses rangs le
square et mon savoir si à la fin on perd
le sport en régie parce qu'on sait même
pas si on est cette zakat warnaco qu'un
set et cut
maintenant il peut sonder deux points et
après 3.32 norme légale
il ya un an et à un moment donné ils ont
trouvé une solution qu'ils ont au moins
trois coups un petit pont qui paie sa
conscience
logiquement 7 5
vous êtes prêts les amis voilà ça peut
tout basculer si c'est une histoire et
que retrouver le bon ok en fait il faut
juste qu'on répond plus vite que est
comme ça vous êtes prêts attention ne
reste pas sur les mauvaises choses du
passé qui te font du mal car le passé
c'est le passé
qu'est ce que tu as écrit
quelle est votre réponse et skype c'est
un [ __ ] de maladie pouvait remonter au
dessus c'est donc que c'est le cas de
mauvaise réponse parce que pascal
voitures passaient devant donc je pense
que l avait donné bravo encore que tu
fallu que je suis c'est bien vous le
souci est très bien j'ai envie de dire
enfin que tous merci très fort d'avoir
suivi soleil merci pression des 200 mm
merci de me permettre
200 par adulte et merci au lieu du space
shooter que de nous avoir accompagnés
merci au charmant invités d'être là le
vous les copains je vais vous envahir
son peuple à attention le décor d'un
coût de leur business et le revoir
en ce sens elle tué 116 personnes ont
rappelé qu'un téléphone et la régie est
ce que quelqu'un un téléphone times
photos à tout parent c'est parfait il
faut pas le choix ils sont encore en
règle et la mélodie abonnez vous mettez
les bleus ont fait d'elle au findel
dernières photos et merci les invités
merci merci merci merci merci le youtube
fait sa demande
je pense qu'on doit rien entendre dans
les micros reste avec le bordel on fait
des gros bisous et on peut couper
[Musique]